okay he knows it never comes but also a
bar by example
[Music]
96 from john cox to eb instead here
all
ap to atlanta cultured in Roman taba I was going
good for the Sardinian silhouette to revive the world
[Music]
also of the chips that is now up to me but the
Andrea barrel m those too is enough
half an hour
[Music]
eaten he wanted the threw rufai palagi
white taipana between mola does not run there a
Panama
[Music]
cheering steel knees scared he says harsh
bullies ahead in the capital half ball
i went to the canas here
[Music]
it was very far from health care
beautiful of the two are the taranto monde
what I feel about costa fermana for the thesis
history will not have
[Music]